kill every Targaryen I get my hands on
it wasn't us isn't it everybody is
Charlie we got some new Game of Thrones
to talk about there's new early release
date news we also got some more casting
news for the prequel series and there's
a couple more really cool details within
that Entertainment Weekly preview that I
did a video for a little while ago so we
got to break it down there's a new round
of that fire and blood book giveaway
that's coming out later this month all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video most important thing that I saw
after that preview came out was people
referring to an even earlier police
state than we had expected so there's a
release window that HBO is trying to hit
and they don't know exactly when it's
going to happen but when everybody was
freaking out a couple days ago after our
Entertainment Weekly released all this
information there were people that were
trying to tell me that it claimed that
the release date would be during March
2019 and not during April like we had
expected I went back did an internal
page search on all the Entertainment
Weekly articles there was no mention of
March and 2019 in the same sentence
together anywhere in any of those
articles so I don't know where
everybody's getting the March 2019 from
what happened is is a while ago earlier
this year there was a visual effects
supervisor that did an interview where
he said there's no way in hell that
we'll be able to finish all of our
visual effects shots before June they're
just way too many then immediately after
that HBO tried to debunk that statement
by saying the season 8 would premiere
early in 2019 the only reason why
they're vague like just saying early
2019 is because it really does take
forever to finish and render all those
special effects shots and just like
really big effects heavy movies like
Avengers infinity war they're usually
polishing things right down to the last
day before they have to say hand over
episodes to HBO so they can premiere
them for everyone around the world
but unlike a giant tentpole movie if HBO
finds out like late in the process they
need an extra few weeks to finish more
shots they can just delay the premiere
by a few extra weeks it's almost
impossible for big movie studios to do
that because of all the work that goes
into coordinating movie premieres all
around the world and all the marketing
that goes into that but remember that
crazy block of ice stunt that HBO pulled
last year when they were trying to
announce the season 7 premiere date
the same thing is coming for all of us
there's only one wall of apostasy the
grimoire
and it is here
that happened four months before the
official premiere date so I'm just
expecting the same treatment this year
albeit with a little extra footage so
the first teaser that they released for
season seven was literally than just
walking through the different castles
through Dragonstone through King's
Landing through Winterfell and that was
it there were very few if any special
effects shots so HBO could release
something like that anytime they wanted
but they're probably waiting on is just
to get a little bit closer to have a
much more precise idea for when they're
gonna be able to finish all those
special effects so regardless of whether
season 8 drops March 31st or April 21st
sometime in between there they'll
probably drop that first footage to
confirm the release date at least four
months before which would be before
Christmas the reason why April 21st is
the latest date that they could possibly
premiere is is because they announced
that all six of the episodes would air
before the Emmys cut off that's the last
day in the year you can air an episode
of television and it can be nominated
for an Emmy in that same year I think
when people see it they understand
they're gonna understand why it took so
long so it's really not if no one's
going on vacation no one's slacking off
it's just that last season is far beyond
what we've ever attempted before and
it's taking a really [ __ ] long time
but uh I hope it'll be worth it the
cutoff date is May 31st so you do the
easy math what's six Sunday's before May
31st that's April 21st so that's the
last Sunday that they could possibly
premiere and still hit that cutoff date
there are also a lot of people that feel
like they might release some sort of
teaser and announce the premiere date
before the end of November around the
Thanksgiving holiday so if that ends up
happening I will totally do a video for
it but I'm not expecting any like real
big footage till closer to the end of
the year but if you remember back a
couple seasons when they used to
premiere seasons earlier in the year
April late March they would release
teasers around this time of the year
anyway so there will be a lot of Game of
Thrones related stuff happening between
now and the end of the year including
that george RR martin fire and blood
book release which is in a couple weeks
the person that did that Entertainment
Weekly preview James Hibbard also had a
really interesting passage talking about
a new location that he
saw that they use at the end of the
season that they had never done before
so for instance you have your King's
Landing set that's where the Iron Throne
is and we've seen Daenerys as visions it
seems like it's gonna get burnt or
destroyed or partially torn down during
the finale there's been a lot of
foreshadowing that there might not be an
Iron Throne after this war with the
knight King so when James Hibbard during
this article is saying that he got to
see a set they constructed for the
finale that had never been seen on Game
of Thrones before it's totally possible
that it becomes the new seat of power if
there's not going to be an Iron Throne
so whatever arrangement the surviving
rulers of the seven different kingdoms
have with whoever winds up becoming King
whoever ends up surviving Jon Snow
Daenerys or both of them it sounds like
that room might be something like that
where it kind of shows you what they're
going to be doing going forward and how
that's different from what's been
happening in the history of A Song of
Ice and Fire the entire series has been
called a game of Thrones so it would be
kind of funny to end on a bunch of
different Thrones albeit the
relationship between all the different
rulers are a little bit different but
that doesn't really tell you who lives
who dies so let me know in the comments
there's a brand new set that's never
been seen on Game of Thrones before that
they're filming their final scenes for
for the finale what do you think that
set is going to be the other really cool
casting news for the prequel series is
they just cast Josh White House is a
main character he definitely looks like
he could be related to Robb Stark's so
I'm guessing that he might be a
northerner and since they've announced
Naomi Watts in her you know aspiring
socialite backstory I do like the theory
that she could be a gender bent land the
clever because the whole set up for her
character was is that she was this
aspiring socialite with a really dark
secret and it would be a pretty dark
secret if she were the person that
conned house cast early out of the rock
in started house lannister conning their
families way into the aristocracy of
Westeros because if she's an aspiring
south bran socialite lady it would be
very hard for them to gain respect if
they only conned their way into the
famous Lannister fortune so right now
that is my new favorite theory about who
she's playing but obviously they haven't
said officially and they haven't said
who Josh White House is playing either
it's just that he looks so much like
Robb star
that I'm guessing that he's a northerner
but let me know in the comments who do
you think that he is playing and what do
you think about the gender bent land the
clever theory they haven't wasted any
time in announcing new main cast members
for the prequel series so I'm guessing
between now and the end of the year
we'll find out who the rest of the cast
is because they're supposed to start
shooting that in February so by that
time we'll know exactly when season 8 is
gonna premiere we'll have already gotten
our first really big trailer so there'll
be a lot of really cool game of Thrones
stuff happening congratulations mister
crafter you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Game of Thrones video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for that big episode 1 preview and
click here for my new Arya Stark video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight